citizens of the reject Nation She-Hulk just had
its finale as in like seven minutes ago we just
finished the finale and you know your boy likes
lists and with that finale it has changed where
she helped would rank so let's rank all of the
Disney Plus shows all right now please do leave
a like that does help the algorithm right there
there's a button it's a thumb that's a positive
thing everybody likes a good thumbs up we do
that digitally it helps this channel just grow
and exist also please leave your ranking in the
comments because I genuinely want to know how
you perceive these shows what order you have and
remember this is my experience of these shows my
life is inherently different than yours because
I've lived a different life than yours this is how
I perceive the art isn't one is better than the
other these are my favorites and how I journeyed
through these Marvel Disney Plus shows please do
also follow me on Tick Tock we got 15 seconds we
got 30 seconds we got three minute reviews and
videos and news and fan casts all sorts of stuff
that you'd see here but a little bite size segment
so hunt me down over there you guys have been
great follow me over there I really appreciated
it all right enough Preamble let's get into it
coming in at number nine is what if now I did talk
about this on the full breakdown of my entire MCU
experience so I'll be brief but for me what if
didn't feel like it had quite the same amount of
weight as other shows or other installments in the
MCU I felt like those little micro universes were
kind of isolated to themselves and unfortunately
by the time Multiverse of Madness came out and
then zombie Wanda and zombie strange weren't those
characters it made it feel even more erroneous and
yes comic books are like that and yes there are
times where issues don't matter that much but in
the greater scheme of the MCU everything has felt
really impactful until some things recently and
what if was the first time I was like okay I'm
enjoying this but it doesn't feel like must see
TV so it is my lowest one of the Marvel Disney
Plus shows at number eight we've got Hawkeye
now Hawkeye was one of my most anticipated that
actually might be partly my fault for this being
so low because my expectations were impossibly
high I'm a huge fan of Jeremy Renner I am a
huge fan of Haley Steinfeld I love their Dynamic
together I love how they both perfectly embody
Hawkeye and Hawkeye now unfortunately that's about
where it ends for me I didn't really love the B
plots I didn't love The Supporting Cast as much as
I usually do with these shows not that they were
bad but one of these things has to be number eight
so it's just lower because of The Supporting Cast
didn't quite land for me I did enjoy that it was
an adaptation of an incredible Hawkeye run but I
didn't really feel for move abroad guys I didn't
really feel for the villainous Syndicate it also
didn't make me fully endeared to Echo as much
as I wanted to because I love echo in the comic
books it did a lot of things right but it left
me feeling Hollow and then that might have been
you know a reasonable thing if not for the way I
thought Kingpin came about the The kingpid Landing
did really bother me uh we still don't know what's
going to be Canon to the Netflix world or any of
those things but it did feel like we got a fully
Who Framed Roger Rabbit almost cartoon Kingpin
and Vincent D'Onofrio is one of the most grounded
powerful sincere Earnest interesting takes in all
of comic book adaptations so it was really hard to
see him go from the Wilson fist we got on Netflix
to this character and it did just feel a little
disingenuous so that gives me Hawkeye at Number
Eight coming in at number seven is the show we
just wrapped She-Hulk she-hulk's finale actually
put this over Hawkeye this would have been the
number eight spot but after that finale I was so
impressed I really loved the first two episodes
and then I loved the last two episodes even more
the first two and the last two are amongst my
favorite of anything in the Disney plus Marvel
Pantheon and especially those last two episodes
I would put up against a lot of the entirety of
the MCU unfortunately I did struggle with some of
the stuff in the middle unfortunately I was aware
of run time at times I'm also not a sitcom guy
so a lot of the sitcom tropes did didn't quite
sing for me the same way I did appreciate its
humor I loved its Madness I thought the writing
was really incredible and I thought the acting was
incredible what's interesting for my brain is that
sitcom writing and sitcom acting feel separate
like there's a disconnect for me where I can be
like I can acknowledge that's good writing I
can acknowledge that's good acting this isn't
my tempo for lack of a better phrase that said I
am really impressed at the genius of the not just
forethought of what's going to be the effect of
this on Pulp culture in the trolling in the mess
that we deal with in the fandom side of commentary
but in the finale they had literally spelled out
everything that they knew was going to be the
experience this show is not written live this
isn't filmed live before a studio audience this
was known by these writers and that's incredible
it was able to play with awareness in the same way
that She-Hulk did in the comic books in the John
Burton run of Shield she literally is referencing
iconic covers on her covers there's parallels
between storylines happening at the time of Pop
Culture that you can then go reread and experience
pop culture in that moment in time now you can do
that with this show this Disney plus experience
is unique to this time we are here for a moment
in time that we got to experience through the
beautiful lens of Shield so for that that's an
A plus that experience is like nothing I'm ever
going to experience again the first time you watch
The Shield finale that is a before and after life
moment which I have to sing the Praises of it just
didn't work for me in the middle bit and that you
know that happens so that makes it number seven
love that exists really appreciate the fact that
I had a once in a lifetime moment with it but
something has to be number seven number six the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier I feel like this is
a show that is only going to improve with time and
how it's perceived by pop culture I feel like when
Captain America four comes out people are gonna be
like oh my God I did love Falcon in the Winter
Soldier this show does what a lot of phase four
does but does it extremely well and then it deals
with grief there's the running joke that after end
game everyone needs to go to therapy hey guys
Winter Soldier goes to therapy in this show I
love that it faces grief head-on I love that it
faces grief in two different actions I love that
the mantle of Captain America is passed to Falcon
for a reason and we see why Bucky wasn't the guy
to take the shield and more importantly we see why
Sam Wilson was the guy to take the shield we also
get introduced to an incredible new Falcon we also
get so much great Baron Zemo Baron mordo is Doctor
Strange Baron Zemo is the this this winter soldier
situation and I really love Daniel Rule's take on
Baron Zemo I think the Espionage angle is great
I love the Winter Soldier movie style Dynamic and
I thought they brought that really well into this
show my biggest flaw with this show is as much as
I love in comic books when villains and heroes
Team Up Against All Odds I did find Baron Zemo
just being chummy with our guys so immediately
like I don't think either of these guys would
trust him even to the level they did obviously
there was distrust throughout the episodes there
was moments of oh no I don't believe him but it
did feel like wait a second Baron zemo's just just
pounding around now he literally is the reason
for civil war so that did rub me the wrong way a
little bit but that's more than made up for with
the USA agent that's more than made up for with
that incredible bloodiest moment to that date
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe of the heading
I also give this a little bit of Wiggle because
this was a covid Juggle Shuffle thing with plot
lines and it dealt with a lot so I'm a big Bucky
Barnes fan it's great to see him get to sing I'm
a big Sam Wilson fan it was great to see him get
to sing I think this show is only going to improve
people's eyes as time goes on number five nights
Moon Knight is really really interesting in that
it almost had the opposite of the She-Hulk problem
they kind of acknowledge the Moon Knight problem
in She Hulk I don't love that most of these
shows are really really powerfully dynamic in
their dialogue and their pros and they take their
time and they experience things and then there's
a big fight at the end Moon Knight dropped a
decent amount of spots after that finale that
did not work for me as well as I wanted it to
that said everything else did I love that this
felt like event TV I love that week to week I was
so intrigued by this world I was so enamored by
Mark spector's entire existence sorry Jake sorry
it's everyone in that world and I wanted to know
all of them I wanted to experience everyone as
we went through that and the acting I think Oscar
Isaac's performance here is some of the best on
TV period hardstyle I think Ethan Hawke is such
an interesting captivating villain up until the
finale when they're going against each other just
a power of wills and intelligence that is such a
captivating show and it's more interesting than
giant deities fighting and that's the past hour
of Marvel is that the people talking is just as
powerful as deities fighting and it slipped at
the end but the whole journey to get to the end
was a master class in style and substance some
of the shots from Aaron and Justin the directors
of some of the episodes were so Dynamic and so
powerful from the comic iconography it looked
like Greg Smallwood art come to life and then
other episodes directed by Muhammad diab felt
so much like what the beating pulse of the comic
is we got visuals and we got heart this show was
so special I really got a lot out of it I'm very
excited to see more Moon Knight in the MCU number
four Miss Marvel herself Kamala Khan that show
was like six months ago or three months ago and
time is a flat circle but the entire time it was
airing I was so infatuated with us getting our
modern silver age Spider-Man this character to me
is what I imagine it's like to go through being
young now and that's what it felt like when I was
reading Spider-Man growing up she's fighting for
her hometown she's dealing with family stuff she's
just going up against the odds she's the ultimate
Underdog and this show captured all of that and
much like the comic book informed me a lot about
a culture I don't have that much knowledge of
I don't know a lot about Muslim culture this
show brought me into that world brought me into
that family and then in a very special episode
brought me back to a giant historic event that I
knew very little about I knew very little about
everything that happened in that flashback and
then that tied up beautifully into the modern
day and then the finale was incredible the reason
this one's so high is it broke some of that oh no
they don't know how to do a finale feeling I had
had where the ending is like a home alone episode
in a school and it plays with powers it gives you
one of the biggest Cliffhangers in Marvel history
with the sound cue of the X-Men it reveals her as
a mutant in such a clever way and it does all of
that while never being inauthentic to the PACE
the tone and the feel of the show going forward
Mount Khan is a character that's all of us she is
literally a fan and the actress Amon villani is
literally all of us she's one of the biggest fans
and that is Miss Marvel Miss Marvel is in complete
Idol ship of an Adoration of Captain Marvel we
felt that every step of the way and we felt Amman
being us every step of the way and they were still
able to tell this incredible story with tons of
incredible set pieces and lots of Genius dialogue
really loved me to Miss Marvel and a lot of points
go to that finale which I really dug number three
just aired last week and since it didn't have
theatrical we're calling it a show but it is a
special event it is werewolf By Night World by
night was one of my biggest surprises out of d23
because I was so ready for this as is but as not a
giant horror comic guy I was like I'm gonna enjoy
it I enjoy a lot of what Marvel put it that puts
out but when I saw that trailer I was bowled over
by potential I was like they're making a full-on
70s Grindhouse film and then what I got was even
better a full-on 30s Universal monster movie
experience this is what I want out of Marvel when
they take such bold swings that you're fully in
another world this movie didn't end with a giant
action set piece it stayed in tone this special
event didn't steer away from how it started in
that pulpy goodness it didn't rush it didn't do
anything that was not authentic to its story and
it debuted Michael giaccino's directing career
hopefully to go on and do everything because the
world he made was so immediately interesting the
three characters that he was able to capture so
quickly with man thing werewolf by night and Elsa
Bloodstone three characters that are not easy to
capture even in comic books that all were absolute
powerhouses that I care so much for that I can't
wait to see where they go next and then that color
transition at the end man thing is man thing
Ted is Ted here and I loved loved Gail Garcia
Bernal here as werewolf by night I cannot wait
to see more of how he interacts with others and
they can do all of this as a period piece or not
they could bring them forward because we don't
have werewolves age and we know Elsa bloodstones
Bloodstone allows for more time we have so much
potential here and it's a thing out of time in
its own way so yes they can interact or not and
I want more of that in the MCU comic books don't
have to all tie together some of them do I would
love to see the midnight Suns here in this world
this darker world this gritty world I I loved
everything about world by Night check out our
reaction on this very Channel we do a whole review
I could talk about that for 20 minutes it's so
special coming in at 9 number two is one division
this one's tricky because I actually juggled
between World finite and one division for two
to three because I think one division is the best
event television we've had yet in the MCU I think
it was the best time in the commentary culture I
think we were all guessing and sharing and it felt
like an actual water cooler show every single week
I literally did Instagram lives for an hour the
moment after I finished an episode and just shared
theories and had people in their commenting it was
a community that is so special Community is what
I feel like I wanted a comic book shop when I'm
standing in the back of a comic book shop flipping
through something someone comes up and recommends
something else or we start a conversation that's
what Comics are to me it's a community this was
one Division I loved the ship of Theseus I loved
what it was like to process grief this way I loved
all the Mysteries and twists and turns but then it
did land with a lot of that getting thrown away to
to have a big apocalyptic ending and that didn't
work as much for me as I wanted it to if it landed
like the number one spot would be fighting
for number one instead it's fighting between
two and three three but it did infinitely more
right than it did wrong I loved getting Spectrum
this way I loved using Darcy this way I love that
Wanda got an incredible Arc to get close to being
Scarlet Witch which then got rushed a bit but I
love that we had time to go from Wanda towards
Scarlet which I love that we got to process comic
books are serialized comic books come out monthly
every month I get to visit some of my favorite
characters and live with them in those pages in
one division every week I got to visit some of my
favorite characters and lived with them in those
frames and that was such a unique time in TV and
I'll always remember it finally one division is my
number two coming in number one you probably
guessed because it's the only one left it is
Loki low-key to me no notes no changes would want
nothing different every scene of dialogue between
Mobius and Loki every moment shared between Owen
Wilson and Tom Hiddleston every single character
Supporting Cast lead cast day player extra stunt
person Masterpiece and then you get to have the
Mysteries you get to play with continuity you get
to do time travel you get to incorporate all the
weird curviness of the Marvel comic books you get
to do what comic books are which is seemingly have
a boundless budget and boundless imagination you
get to play you get to have a sense of play we met
variants we met a crocodile Loki we had a classic
Loki in the incredible Richard E Grant we had so
many moments that are so memorable so many quotes
that made me so introspective so many things that
felt like they were pulled from the comics but
that also felt unique to the medium of TV so many
visuals so much Splendor so much Wonder so much
rate sci-fi so much Mobius art ironically because
the other characters named Mobius in the show
so much love even the Love Story between Loki of
course loki'd love himself so much right and then
best of all it stuck The Landing we meet he who
remains and he is every bit what Kang needs to be
without being Kang we meet the idea of a man that
knows there are others of him that's lived through
time we meet what's about to be the big threat of
phase five and he's terrifying and intense but
also not the scariest version we're gonna get we
get teased just enough to know that Kang is coming
without meeting Kang because that's what you can
do with this character we get a Shakespearean
finale for a show about life about what it means
to be a person what it means to be faded what it
means to make choices we get all that in these
incredible monologues masterfully delivered by
Jonathan Majors this show to me is what you can
do when you have perfect writing perfect directing
perfect acting and let the audience to experience
it with you week to week taking its time setting
up what's to come not only is it great by itself
as a perfect little experience it's also great
as a gateway to what's to come it's also great
as a launching point to introduce characters
that's comic books comic books are great in the
22 Pages you get them they're also great when
you get them in a trade paperback they're also
great when you get them on a hardcover experience
in the whole year or six months or whatever size
hardcover it is they're also great when they're
mixed into events that's low-key it's the thing
that glues it all together as well as its own
beautiful story and it's all done at an A plus
and Loki is a masterpiece and I love each and
every one of these shows again they just had to
be in an order something had to be last something
had to be in the middle something had to be first
any of these things I had an incredible time
watching I gotta know what your ranking is I
got nine what if eight Hawkeye seven She-Hulk six
Falcon Winter Soldiers five Moon Knight four Miss
Marvel three World by night two one Division and
one Loki leave your ranking in the comments below
let me know what you thought of mine be nice as
you you can't like subscribe do YouTube things as
well hunt me down on Tick Tock you guys have been
really great about koi's comic Corner we're going
to be making more I know it was a little slow for
a minute there but we're back let me know in the
comments also what you want to see whether it's uh
you know fan casting or comic recommendations or
any sort of lists and things maybe why not watch
another movie you want me to watch Superman too
let me know also comic recommendations here read
she-hulk's current run it's really special it's
really fun it's kind of the opposite of the show
in that she cannot rep supers and then the X-Men
try to court her as far as Hawkeye check out the
Matt fraction David aha run uh which is based off
of which the show is based off of it's really
fun it's really Dynamic it's really accessible
that's your Hawkeye recommendation let's do
one more let's go Greg Smallwood let's go Greg
Smallwood's Moon night realm with Jeff Lemire
if those are your recommendations as always
enjoy some comics and I appreciate each and every
one of you citizens rejection we'll see you soon
foreign